final space as I said I have no
connection to the project other than I
saw it and I loved it and I thought this
should be on television this is
completely your vision and it's really
it's funny and it's sweet and it's
there's a lot about it that just felt
texturally very different to me so I
don't know we have a clip here I don't
know if is anything you want to say
about the show well before we saw the
clip for that yeah I just want to say
man thank you so much for just giving me
a shot yo I mean
you know I've always been that like
last-place guy and to have TBS and you
give me a shot man I just want to shake
your hand yo yeah this is the clip it's
essentially Gary and avocado get trapped
in this oblivion cube and I like that
you're talking like everybody knows
exactly what you're talking about you
know Gary novel cada you know what I'm
talking about
yeah they get trapped in this oblivion
cube and all they're like basically
whatever they think becomes reality and
Gary's obsessed with cookies so there we
go here we go say whoa this clip from
final space I'm a very creative guy like
wouldn't it be cool if Ted like laser
eyes
Oh
[Applause]
you